my name is Emma Dina Nagato and the
managing partner of ernst & young Gary
and Ethiopia and the head of our
transaction is violence services in
Eastern Africa which includes Kenya in
valence of other countries I'm very
happy to be here we're happy to have the
World Economic Forum come to a DS and as
part of that this year just like last
year we didn't we didn't cake down at
least our Africa attracted in a survey
where we interviewed 500 global
executives about Africa and the
potential for doing business here and I
just wanted to quickly share with you
what the results were the highlights the
first part of it under the 500 300 have
already quick money in Africa and 200
have not and what we found is the dimer
opposing a response to the question we
ask is Africa an attractive investment
destination compared to other fights
over the world and resoundingly without
exception those of good money in Africa
said that with the exception of Asia
Africa is a better destination to put
money to do business on the other hand
with on a very large scale the others
who have not put money which is
approximately 200 and the 500 have told
us that Africa is not a very attractive
place to do business there for our
recommendation is that for investors by
African governments to make sure that
the message the positive message the
improvements and those who said this
positive actually can become brand
ambassadors for Africa and tell the
world that actually do business the
perception of actually doing business
compared to the reality there is a huge
gap and that needs to be brought to a
closer understanding of what it is the
reality on the ground so I thank you
very much